well you want to stop her and sean
manaya is capable of doing exactly that
swinging with an instructor man exuding
confidence hands over the head the turn
in the 2-2 pitch now swung on of miss
and for manaya it's a one two three top
of the first with two strikeouts
and they'll take their swings off
baltimore's own bruce zimmerman with
gloriano at first and here's matt olson
he's gonna have a base hit gets it
through the ship loriano digging for
third he'll make it
so matt olsen on the first pitch he sees
now loriano is going to try to score
as the ball gets away the throw to the
plate he's safe
the ball trickles behind home plate
olson's going to end up
at third
jed lowry switch hitter bounding right
one will pitch to lowry base it left
here
olsen will trot home and the a's lead to
nothing
the jed lowry he needed that hit
[Applause]
here's the 2-2 delivery now and that's
taken on the inside corner bringing him
up bronco can't believe it
isn't sean to the plate it's swung out
of his try to time an off-speed pitch
and couldn't
fourth strikeout already for mania now
freddie galvez
trying to deliver a two-out base hit
with severino in scoring position
two strike pitch line right field that
gets severino around 30. he's headed to
the plate
and the orioles put one on the board
nice job by freddie galvez delivers
with two out
two down and austin hayes steps in the
2-2 pitch from sean manaya to austin
hayes
and this one's hit deep to left center
field back is
canna looking up and that baby's gone
austin hayes a solo home run and this
game is tied at two
nobody needs batting gloves brett who
needs him when you're as hot as austin
hayes is
three hits in the series that one
absolutely crushed
murphy's awarded for space second a's
batter that's been hit today
and that'll bring matt olsen to the
plate
oh my gosh matt olsen are you kidding me
are you kidding me matt olson goes dead
center on bruce zimmerman a two-run
blast
his seventh of the year and it's 4-2
oakland
payoff pitch from monae and here it
comes swank and a mess he got him a
chase of fastball off the plate away
and he's gone on strikes
here comes the 2-2 pitch and he got him
good breaking ball there
hit hard into left field and it's a base
hit knocked down by canna has to short
hop it
that one got out there in a hurry d.j
stewart with a knock
a little pop pop-up short right field
and that's going to fall
so austin hayes dumps it in stewart
advances to third
and the orioles got a little something
going here with you down good to see the
orioles get a little bit of love on some
bloopers
so a line drive single from stuart and
then
a bloop single from austin hayes runners
on the corners two down for mancini
treo for two with a strikeout and a
bounce out to third
gets away from murphy but not far enough
they do get an
advance from hayes but not far enough
for dj stewart to come home bounced into
left field this should score
two and it does mancini with a clutch
two out base hit and the orioles have
tied it at four
all four oriole runs in this game have
come with two outs
[Applause]
that one was drilled toward right field
nobody's going to get it
it's an over the wall on a bounce and
matt olsen
back in the lineup has got a single a
double in a home run
this is unbelievable olson at third
moreland at first two strikes to seth
brown
and he got him high heater couldn't
catch up to it
and the a's retired in the fifth inning
3-2 pitch bounce to second
oh no gets away everybody's safe
the flip to second not a good one
and the orioles get a break two on and
one down
all four runs have come with two down
mancini drove into his last at bat
line drive base hit right center field
arias around
third he will score the orioles take the
lead
5-4 as trey mancini is now driven in
three runs
with two out just a little
inside out swing
boy that's a good piece of hitting head
down shoulders square
just a rocket out towards right center
field
that's the guy we've been watching for a
few years right
that's a guy that drove in 97 hit 35
home runs
the a's get the time right on and now
here comes matt olson
one-two pitch he got him sir froze him
lined up the middle into center field
for a base hit
around second is murphy he's into third
he's out
oh he's out of there
franco applies the tag
and a big base running blunder so here's
lowry who's two for three
so fry readies chapman a good lead at
second
grounded toward third franco to his left
makes a nice play his throws wide and
now
chapman's gonna score the time run
mancini couldn't get it out of his glove
chapman never stopped running and we're
tied
well orioles need another two odd base
hit all the runs have come that way dj
stewart
loriano's got to get back still going
back near the wall
and he caught it wow
stuart can't believe it the orioles
dugout can't believe it
we can believe it because we've seen it
before
from the laser ramon moriano
ramon lauriana will hit he's one for
four
[Applause]
that one's hit well right field stewart
back stewart at the wall
and that baby's gone
[Music]
he puts the a's on his back and he gives
the a's a 7-5 lead
a's seven orioles five two on one out
top of the ninth
and mancini is coming up second and the
delivery is swung on in
line to left center canada coming over
goes into a slide and
backhands it and the runners get back
rolled toward ulster he's got it he'll
step
on first and that's the ball game
so the a's needed to win to salvage the
final game of this series and they get
it they had a fight for it
but the brightest shining star today for
the a's
is ramon laureano